Speaker 1: Did Donald Trump as president have
the right to unilaterally declassify documents
just based on his say so? That's one of the
conversations we've been having ever since the
FBI raid on Donald Trump's home in Florida last
week took place. And we know that the American
right wing, they've been throwing everything at
the wall to see what sticks as it pertains to
the FBI raid in Mar a Lago, saying everything
from this is a witch hunt to the FBI, planted
documents on Donald Trump. But one of the more
pernicious claims made in right wing media circles
lately has been that even if Donald Trump did
have classified documents in his possession,
in his basement in Mar a Lago, that's A-OK,
because presidents at the end of the day,
are the ultimate authority as to what is
classified information and what gets declassified.
So it doesn't matter. It's kind of a get out of
jail free card if the president does it. It's
not illegal, as Richard Nixon once said. Here's
one such example of this claim being made by Kash
Patel, who is a former Trump administration
official who now works over at Truth Sociale,
also known as Truth Central. He made the claim
to Fox News's Maria BARTIROMO over the weekend
on her Sunday show. Let's take a look at that.
Speaker 6: In October of 2020, he issued a
sweeping declassification order for every
Russiagate document and every single Hillary
Clinton document. Then, on the way out of the
White House, he issued further declassification
orders, declassifying whole sets of documents.
And this is a key fact that most Americans are
missing. President Trump as a sitting president
is a unilateral authority for declassification.
He can literally stand over a set of documents
and say these are now declassified and that
is done with definitive action immediately.
Speaker 1: So Kash Patel here in this video
makes it sound like there's almost a magic spell
involved. Like Donald Trump could just wave his
hand over the documents in question and then,
poof, they are no longer classified information.
So nothing to be seen here. Nothing to be
investigated. Well, you may be shocked to learn
that this is not actually how the process works.
Presidents do have the ability to declassify
certain types of information, but there's a
procedure attached to it. Certain executive
branch officials have the authority to deem
information as confidential, secret or top
secret. And if it's ultra top secret, then the
document will get the CIA designation. Some of the
documents in Donald Trump's possession had this
very distinction. There are also rules limiting
how the documents can be stored, physically
transported or electronically transmitted
when someone with the proper authority moves to
declassify the documents. The executive branch
has a process to involve the other agencies that
might be affected. And certainly the president is
one of the people who can move to make something
declassified. It's rarely done, but it can happen.
However, they need to undergo this very
same process and it's not as easy as
waving a magic wand as capital would have
you believe. Here's former CIA director and
former Defense Secretary Leon Panetta, who would
know a thing or two about this very topic being
even more frank than I have been about the
process for how to declassify documents.
Speaker 7: So you're obviously very well versed
in dealing with classified material. Former Trump
aides are now trying to claim that there was a
standing order by the president, Donald Trump,
to declassify any document that left
the West Wing for Trump's president.
Is that how declassification works, even with
some of the nation's most guarded secrets?
You know, that's nonsense. And and he knows
it. The reality is that there is a process
for declassifying information. And if presidents
want to declassify, they have to follow that
process, which basically requires that it be
referred to the agencies that are responsible for
classifying that material. They have something
to say as to whether or not that material
should be declassified. So there is nothing that
I'm aware of that indicates that a formal step was
taken by this president to, in fact, declassify
anything. Right now, this is pretty much.
Speaker 1: B.S. It's all a bunch
of B.S., says Leon Panetta.
And then there's an added layer of security
when you're talking about nuclear documents,
which Donald Trump is accused of having in his
possession as documents about nuclear material
are subject to the Atomic Energy Act, which the
president does not have unilateral authority over.
Now, secondary to this entire discussion is that
even if the documents were unclassified or even
if they were deemed declassified by Donald Trump
right before he left office with his magic wand,
it wouldn't serve to get the former president
out of hot water because none of the things that
Donald Trump is being investigated for require
the documents be classified. The Espionage Act
violations, concealing documents and obstruction
of justice are the three things that the FBI is
looking into as it pertains to Donald Trump. Those
are not dependent on whether the information that
Trump had in his possession were classified. He's
not supposed to be taking, hiding or destroying
any of the presidential records regardless of
their classification status. And the government
asked him to return the items he didn't willingly
hand them over. He didn't give back all of the
documents anyway. And so it doesn't matter whether
or not they were classified. Final point on this,
because the right has been talking nonstop
about Hillary Clinton and her emails over
the past couple of weeks. They used to say that
Hillary Clinton, she could not be trusted to
handle secret information, therefore she could
not be president because when she was secretary
of state, she had secret documents in her Gmail
accounts that was being operated through a private
server and it was grossly negligent. We just can't
trust her with these top secret documents. Well,
if that was ever your concern, but you also now
have this position that the president can just
declassify whatever they want on a whim. Doesn't
this render the point that they were making
about Hillary in 2016 completely moot? Like, why
would it matter that Hillary Clinton supposedly
wasn't able to be trusted with classified
information if she would have the power as
president to just declassify whatever she wants
anyway? But the contradictions we know when it
comes to the right wing, they don't matter. It's
all about twisting and turning yourself. Anything
that you can do to defend Donald Trump no
matter how ridiculous it makes you look.